[Music]
you
a woman's reproductive system includes
the vagina
cervix
uterus
fallopian tubes
and ovaries
during vaginal sex between a man and a
woman
semen passes out of the man's penis into
the woman's vagina in a process called
ejaculation
semen contains tens of millions of sperm
from the vagina sperm can pass through
the cervix uterus and fallopian tubes to
fertilize an egg from the woman's body
fertilization of the egg marks the
beginning of human development
a cervical cap is a form of birth
control or contraception it's a
temporary and reusable device women can
use to prevent pregnancy made of a
flexible rubber
the cervical cap is shaped like a
sailor's hat it has a dome with a
removal strap on top of it
the brim surrounding the dome has a
short side and a long side
a cervical cap should be used with a
substance that kills sperm called
spermicide to increase its effectiveness
a woman puts the cervical cap in her
vagina before having sex to prevent
pregnancy
the dome of the cervical cap covers the
cervix which prevents the sperm in the
man's semen from entering the uterus
the spermicide applied to the cap kills
the sperm that come into contact with it
there are a few things to remember
before using a cervical cap do not use
the cervical cap if you have given birth
within eight to ten weeks or had a
miscarriage or abortion within six weeks
it is easier to become pregnant using a
cervical cap during these times because
the cervix is larger do not use a
cervical cap during the menstrual period
because it can block normal drainage of
blood from the uterus
if you have an infection or other health
condition affecting your uterus cervix
or vagina or if the cap is torn or
damaged
to use a cervical cap wash your hands
and remove it from its container apply
one quarter teaspoon of spermicide
inside the dome up to and including the
brim
apply an additional 1/2 teaspoon of
spermicide in the groove between the
outside of the dome and the brim next
choose a position for you to begin
inserting the cap you can lie down with
your knees bent squat with both feet on
the floor or stand with one foot on a
chair
insert your index and middle fingers all
the way into your vagina to locate your
cervix so that you'll know where to
place the cervical cap
next squeeze the cervical cap with the
dome facing away from your vagina then
slide the cervical cap into your vagina
with the long side of the brim entering
first using one or two fingers slide the
cervical cap as far into your vagina as
it will go check with your fingers to
make sure the cervical cap touches and
completely covers your cervix
you can leave the cervical cap in your
vagina for up to 48 hours
before removing the cervical cap wait
for six hours after the last time you
had sex
to remove it squat with both feet on the
floor insert a finger into your vagina
to find the strap covering the Dome of
the cervical cap gently push the dome
with the tip of your finger to dimpled
it and break the suction attachment to
your cervix then hook your finger
through the strap and pull down slowly
and gently
after removing the cervical cap wash it
with soap and water and allow it to air
dry
the cervical cap is most effective at
preventing pregnancy in women who have
never been pregnant or have never had a
vaginal birth
cervical caps are about 96% effective at
preventing pregnancy if used correctly
every time a woman has sex cervical caps
are about 92% effective with typical use
which means either not always using the
cap or not using it correctly every time
a woman has sex